we have reports place not only in the
callao
it's a big army by a gunsmith
are marked before my revision
youth mark of ignorance that was
in the ass world at the time that bid
expectations
[Applause]
[Music]
and now everyone kills you for silver
before pacific peru manager of 'stable'
of Lima and Callao de countries
main event port it another world first
and distribution point for working to the
north colombia ashmore famous politician
that influences story texture and connect
figueres and pablo escobar in
envelopes the united states badly
but it lost its levels more corners
colombia ministry of campsites of
Rwandan marketing
- morgan with organizations in today
white corruption in the callao alone with
breaking balance andrews slide integrated
wave across the city and the short and be
extra king back yard emperor drug
enforcement and giving access to the
criminal andrew world hunger games of
day live in this bill and drop field
city ​​is an audi meeting a contact es
good you fall to them west affecting
ladies balance
maybe train criminal were ex-convict
with the client was water for peace
Web
avn world the mind notebook white the
change my place to be
[Music]
I was born in the quiet barracks one of
the most dangerous neighborhoods from the heat of
all peru
from vido in a small here to the town of
jump colony my father I brought it to me
they brought to live to give a
good way marín here we do not come to
spoiling is very small at 13 years old and
he drugged me in the same corner he stole
I jumped on the bus with two
knives assaulting all passengers
Miguel wanted me to see the score of the
live blogs in balance red life with
under proof of fossil jazz origin
chinchón coaching local slam mins
but there is a peron in which after
One year I get a tumor
they are marks that wasted my
youthful brands of ignorance that was
in the dark world after violence
of drug killing
now that it was so every octave that what
I sold drugs they did not want to sell me
drug already discarded blame for you
this without a padlock and put knives
the drug sellers hired
six people got some knives the
fisherman got 29 stabs in
all my body
I do not know why I am alive the command and
how it was that he took to give the situation
in which you killed seeing everything was because
look I found a Lima from the
house became my friend who wanted me
underestimate what I grab the worst I did
was to put his hand in my sister's photo
the endurance the second week happened with my
woman puts her hand in pairs of
I had six months of time I did not say
until something I have to do grip
I started to drug myself with the same we got
50 grams of coca in one night I lost the
notion but the only thing that I remember that
I got up to the star I got up with
my beaten seed are in my hand from
blood and my old man approaches me
cleaning Miguel killed him test and that was
that he had put a knife in
throat that I had ten years hidden and
after ten years they come to capture me and
methane reviewing from 8 to 15 years six
months someone
as well
ask him goodbye
without fearing out contests and
sandwiches and good looks hitman guia
member of the most notorious great from
from sarita colonia netbook de shower los
mens
and I admit millimeter round and place of
blogs
identify alias Carlos and what is
aware
a bulletproof vest when one goes out to
changing this protects us a bit from the
death but simply now that we
It's time to die, everyone to die and this is not
we are always among those who are more
friendships I see close friendships I do not know
can there be some friends we have made
throwing to the new murder a robbery
that is called brotherhood but neither is there
than trusting anyone in this world
now everyone kills you for silver
you know
extorting stealing by killing people
do not
just uncovered
there you have fallen bullet
reality and pink
when one has to put lead has
that thinking is really 3 and paw
or to top of a certain reason so it has iron
this is a grenade I've had 4 this
one day they called him and said good look
they know who I have a house are four
causes that are your enemies we throw it to
1 second floor tan with open court
so much watching we walk 5
seconds that's not
died 2
the others know each other leg the other
was deaf and as soon as they buy a
mat nothing are 150 soles
it is equal not to sell
the gang's in the callao lime news this
of dating fuck enjoying in fifty
soles which is raw the fury dollars and if
about them
you say berry clive owen
this
this is a Brazilian taurus 38 caliber
38 have the six ammunition
and now I have an armed struggle for a
callao gunsmith
teaches me
They are also of 32 pens
at the time that you are
1 mission of tutors participated as if
in general terms a trolley of three
blocks with the motorbike
low to the one who is going to liquidate it liquidated
gets on the motorcycle
three blocks away my car waits
motorbike goes alone I go in the car
tranquilito by closing in the car
the motorcycle goes a black motorcycle there is a
veneer is alone in its role of everything
while I'm in the car what
infinite
I take nothing else to force to stick
Old guard iron
in tuenti fifteen decided the callao then
of clerq under state of emergency face
good soldier
the cable is the current goldman
those of mobile application of gas
direct acquiring networks your money
at salem uold works roberts and insurance
respective with hit man ray of motorbike
to virgiliis business icon
emergency with the spirits of politics
water and installation problems working
state of emergency westhuizen de leaf and
of youtube relative de cuisine denver
durate the web callados wave for supply
and women for forming with show that
there was an increase in
drug trafficking by the quiet and how
As a result, we arrived in a month
to have up to 18 dead by facts
violent in which the
state of emergency looking in
restaurants have already been suspended
some civil rights to the person
how is the right to freedom the
right to inviolability at home
that allowed us to provide some
police operations that we have to
give
good here in the callao the weak point in
what refers to traffic is
just the biggest port
amount of out there this situation
that relationship because they appreciate the suitcases
that are stars of the container
eloy of cocaine
the world of drug trafficking there is a
hegemony with other criminal groups
wants to enter wants to take that domain
occurs between rivalries and by
everything is intended to solve
through the sicariato
today commander port racing by
legions of víctor galindo hosts
del callao looking for illegal web people
wanted byd authorities include hitler
charge forces area of ​​responsibility
within all police intervention
I need that I always kept it in the
perimeter that the safety of the staff
who is intervening
Lévinas word is best ancap
we belong to the intelligence team of
police intelligence nets
then it has left problems and left
of webb on filmin and despots translate
and if it's winning which of your feet
today misfortune a certain habitat
and without some the barracks much more
bikes
for c's mood reports place not only
in the quiet for a 6 problem left
the pro
people
[Music]
do not
There is no way
of check in the mobile phones stolen
renewed submitted within the market
black
and obviously for them for some
illicit not for stations charge of yes
let's meet him
the corner question is unknown
because there are people also the same comes and
consume drugs in this equipment there has been
moments in which there have been people
that they were with weapons with was
required by the link we have
intervened
behind them comes the family of the
mom the brother the first neighbor the
friend the school promotion get to
all the neighbors come and try
rescue in some opportunities up
they overcome
plural the afternoon the police
stop cavities in series operation in the
west street social our digital
efforts repressors efforts go less
common and without generating a corner is repeated
in fact a due drug trafficking
they have always used the resource
economic to hire people
very violent and fight for them for the
power struggle with others
drug traffickers also
they are young people who are captured to my mind
with the promise that you do not have to
study, you do not have to strain
put weapons in the hand and product of
that if it's good work song within
that organization you saw us give them from
eating pays them then he is the example
to the other young people how it will go
if you get on the wrong side
here
all right
the contribution of my house signed by all
because my house
and why not
long ago the income to the
barracks without ending to four
chapters with a firearm initially
it was thought good a band
we proceed to verify the cell phone is the
themselves stolen the content of their
cell phones
you see that an affirmation one of them is
I had filmed
of a vehicle and in the back
of the boy boy 11,000 this
fainted we did not know as to whether that
affirmation I would have sent someone
more he did not stop looking at this person anymore
it is cold
[Music]
there is a power struggle between the
same criminals to know who is the
who is in charge of this area
unfortunately at some point
the police was overcome we escaped from
the hand we did not realize but this
year we have already tried to be in all
the critical points of the region
we shut up
this is fernando export waiting amp
collector lists formed but the
deaths that while nate is andoni
forget civil terrestrial waters and
continue to the deep
intel quiet criminal andro world